you just got here it's 221 a.m. at least
for me camels playing let's play camel
let's play the sodium attack against
camel or the reverse sodium attack okay
playing camel there's actually a
positional trap if Bishop takes a 6 I
have Queen a5 and takes I have the
bishop here and I paired that light from
castling funny variation okay we're
gonna have some interesting opening this
is strong players life to not lose
I'm controlling the the sides maybe
slightly questionable wow it's a bit
some read it's a it's a host shock
underscore ara is hosting your hosting
at an awkward time my nights are
slightly dubious also my nights trapped
my nights trapped oh this is bad
oh but maybe it's not trapped you sneaky
move this move too
well let's play sneaky move
counter-attack
yeah who is shocked RL hosting for for
up to 80 viewers is that a chest
streamer like I should know that person
thank you shock RL
yeah if you're joining this is chess
it's a board game
oh you're o RL stands for rocket League
that sounds scientific but also
competitive I take a pong could take a
pong there's actually a nice trap here I
still have to be careful but the idea is
if Bishop takes Knight I double attack
and that would actually be reasonable
for me yeah play f5 yeah five let's do
this if you're joining if you're joining
from shock or else stream wait a minute
Oh cod cod 7 it's funny I open shot
girls twitch and cod 7 is still in shock
arils chat says I love chess hit the
flip reset on the bishop yeah something
about bishops also oh dear
I'm losing the knight now I think I'm
losing the night unless I bow test
gambit and I lose a queen
no this is bad and there's increment too
so I can't actually like dirty flag okay
this is a point in in life like when
things are falling apart you have to be
resourceful to be creative you probably
have to cut your losses rather than
maximize your losses
I'm trying to like approximate what are
the odds I could give camel without
getting completely destroyed
this is really really unfortunate I
completely forgot that [ __ ] yeah I
should g5
there should be five maybe also playable
here but then I have counterplay and
someone's actually wait wait it's not so
bad Queen b6 take stings and then Queen
takes b2
oh maybe it is so bad now I have to play
Queen b6 this is Beth try at least there
there's ways for white to get around
this but we'll see what happens
yeah okay so we'll take and then it's a
question do I take on e4 first let's do
this so I got I got a pawn I've not lost
a single pawn yet I did lose a knight or
bishop or whatever we call it but now
there's some there's some outside chance
of hope I do have a raiding advantage
that's my compensation is my slightly
higher rating which has been just
steadily decreasing with all this mess
every sometimes gg5 is off limits for
the next movers so I'm not gonna give up
I'm only down a piece
I have a little bit of hope b5 is a move
this is a move yeah
if white gets careless I win the bishop
and I fork the king and queen but not
happening and this move maybe it's
getting interesting it take there's all
these forms of compensation whoa it's
anonymous donating dollars oh thank you
appreciate the the praise also the $3.00
that was on on his on on Don's probably
anonymous hmm I'd do this okay wait I
have to focus focus time because their
loss for calculates those takes takes
nights vulnerable I only have a few
moves before black it's safe and defends
everything in castles so I could take
here it's actually kind of interesting
or actually b5 immediately b5
immediately actually it was maximized as
a pressure it gives white a lot of
options and it creates scenarios where
white could go wrong like there's so
much potential
for those who don't know pond tension is
simply when ponds are attacking other
ponds and they don't really take each
other in Peter Bacchus
welcome back Peter shout out to Peter if
you're just joining you you've missed a
lot of things you missed so many things
but you've joined at a time where
there's still more things to come some
idea was to take this way because I'm
not you dad still pins and now I have
Center pons g5 woodwind Connect four and
then it would be double emote g5 and
connect form but this will I was
thinking II four also connect four maybe
there is unstoppable connect four okay
I mean the positions opening up which is
a little bit terrifying for both Kings
oh dear this is gonna be annoying
I have a rookie Yates rookie a d6 King
g7
weights pieces are just so solid but
okay you have to make do with what you
got
Oh Peter just woke up
well good morning or good evening not
sure okay let's do this I'm very
grateful that light doesn't have a dark
side Bishop to destroy me with yeah d6
like it unleash this bishop but it also
opens this diagonal for my bishop the
problem is like whites so close to
castling ninety three ninety three so
close to working
I could take to Queen b6 also
interesting getting very low on time
it's unfortunate it takes so 93 just
doesn't work there should be seven or
takes first he takes first I know I know
I know it's not good but there's lots of
things not good here let's take first
open e-file hey
it's around Ram XII or probably Ram
twelve okay I have a bishop I'm gonna
have open C file - and fianchettoed
Bishop so if like castles like Bishop is
in prime position to attack Oh Ram 12
loves my videos well thank you Ram 12
and you this move
it's interesting
it's worth a try I have 15 seconds I'm
the very little hope but they say I'm
trying to stir up some initiative I'll
probably put the rook on CA next ooh
this move okay so Bishop aligned with
the king rook aligned with the Queen
this is so terrifying my king is finding
shelter in front of my pond
I am still down the piece but it's it's
still kind of complicated we're both
trying to attack on the kingside with
pieces from the queenside it's so we're
like most of our pieces are on the Queen
side and our kings are just kind of
naked on the other side it's casual
scary yeah it's a most chill kind of
scary I mean why couldn't like her pets
probably I wouldn't mind / pets
ooh there's a key Queen maneuver I can't
really avoid the Queen's like
maneuvering like closer it's it's very
it's actually very brilliant the Queen's
able to like continually check me and
and get to the Kings side and be more
relevant in society
so yeah leech s is apt I think they
stopped updating because leach s is
completely responsive all snap it's
completely responsive on any like mobile
browser so if you just go to a beach
just on organ any mobile browser you
should be good to go also oh dear it was
this move what does this move this is
kind of a move this is weird move but
I'm just trying to confuse my opponents
before opponent confuses me
what is this it's so here just hang a
queen okay well I could take a bishop I
mean that's actually kind of it deserves
oh yeah because it like the weird is
good ooh
and the smooth oh it's so weird but it
might it's actually kind of turning
around look at this look at this well
I'm it's like uh it's like the Y in YMCA
with different color things but still
it's kind of nice symmetry and then if
we look at this shape it's like an M
stands for a magic if you turn it upside
down it's a w for weird but the idea is
after it takes bishop takes I win both
nights because V&K dough kebab
I'm still down a minor piece but
alignments hanging nights if rook do you
want d4 yeah let's take a night finding
the fork I'm living on increment five
second increment it's like so I mean
it's not the greatest place to live
oh dear what to do maybe this move play
this move it's like a tucson hotel yeah
it's my life now this move attack upon
threatening to take up Hong with check
also materialized I'm not even down
material I used to be down a piece but
that was the past and this is a future
and a pony getting the one time it's
such a weird game okay I could take with
check and then probably defend it's
complicated again cuz I'm scared about
my bishop being stuck between my pawns
also my pawn is hanging let's take a
pond and maybe give a check
now this is so weird just stay focused
g5 made so close but not quite mates
yeah let's go into f6
[Music]
oh that was a slight panic move please
play King me five please trying to be
polite
now it's only I've three connected
pastors but light has strong outside
passer so it's difficult Wow okay I can
win I win the d6 pawn this is some
progress some sort of progress let's
take I might have to sack at some point
but hopefully not have this move at this
point I'm just trying to make the king I
know I know it's difficult
oh it's very difficult check their check
oh no no oh it's so bad oh it was so
promising just a few months ago No
no this is so unfortunate I tried so
hard to but maybe yes there's some
fortress idea
I'm searching for fortress ideas but I'm
not seeing anything
[Music]
yeah I don't know if I can survive this
to ship in so many pawns oh I have to
just start pushing and pray for the best
it's still weird I gets weird enough for
opponent to maybe go wrong let's put the
bishop I have to about the bishop here
and then we'll finally see the beloved
g5 wait what's the point value that's
seven to ten okay but love it g5 thanks
colonel but don't go wait your if you're
leaving you're you're reaching the
climax of this game about to king e5
maybe can you find like it look at these
pawns oh you have to go oh that's so sad
well watching the future along with it
the YouTube future people unless yeah
unless this has maybe a tragic ending
but it's so interesting still let's push
another pawn to somehow find a way to
advance upon this and not get stuck play
this move there's another panic move but
it makes sense to keep the pawns on dark
squares so my bishop will help control
the light squares in the future
[Music]
in this move oh it's so stressful again
because I might have some chances each
three the so the bishop is defended by
the pawn and supports h3 there was a
nice little construction it's just kind
of still scary gee maybe this move let's
move
oh it seems so close King h3 is a move
opposition there's no work h8 mate it's
writing G 4G 3G - oh it's so interesting
I might win this oh this is so cool but
I'm okay it's still complicated no snap
refresh let's play play this
what's going on ooh that's good move
oh that's another panic move also much
panic but if if King takes bishop I know
it's complicated
have to go for this ooh it's so weird
oh there's interesting idea there's so
interesting idea I have to under promote
tonight's control alts right because
I've promoted Queen I lose the Queen but
promote tonight's defends upon wow this
is my second under promotion in the
stream I defend the the thing I still
might be losing but I have hope
oh do I have hope I have a knight
randomly I always have hope when you
have a knight so we need plot twists
what did you hear bishop here maybe oh
this is so confusing one play g2 don't
harm me we're both living on increments
I have to choose a move hmm yeah teach
once we're only square to defend the
pawn it's so confusing I have this move
oh no that's bad move
let's move freeing h3 I don't think I'm
getting meted oh it's a fork it's a fork
Knights for tonight has returned light
so tricky night so tricky
good thing I promoted tonight oh but
it's so complicated because night is
almost trapped but not quite
what is this position do I save the I
should save this thing right
everything defended bishop defends pawn
everything else defended with a game yes
I come back I was down a piece and then
I was down two rooks you have to move
still quickly I don't want another oh
snap
get Bishop h3 on the horizon I also
don't want it like side meet myself what
do I do here I'm pinned okay let's move
the knight move trap if takes I discover
hmm this move Bishop still defends the
night the pawn is gonna begin to push
and now like here coming yeah okay still
have to stay focused and d3 I should eat
you I have to watch out for the steel
matrix too threatening made into almost
doesn't quite work
what a game what a game yeah check and
then check wow what a game wow I was a
weird game I was a really weird game
that was Edie he moves there were so
many plot twists promoted to our Knights
thanks Danny was yes somehow like the
the rooks the rooks want to like sack
for material but it was tricky
and then this moment like I so I didn't
promote to Queen because this move and
then I lose a queen I'm just losing
promote I don't think I've ever promoted
to a knight to like defend a pawn owner
disky saying roof takes h1 clearest win
oh yeah I was realizing that this is
like I'm in the wrong color corner I
need a dark spirit Bishop I could gain
compact Buffalo thanks Pizza race I'll
put this on YouTube there are lots of
mistakes in that game but it's YouTube
really not very like crazy plot twist
game yeah YouTube people thanks for
watching smash the like button and I'll
see you in the future